Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Back from the Western Antipodes, there has returned one Christopher Columbus, a man from Liguria, who barely obtained three ships from my sovereigns for the voyage, for they had regarded the claims he had been making as utterly fantastical. That was Peter Martyr, an Italian humanist who was chaplain at the court of Ferdinand and Isabella, the king of Aragon, the queen of Castile, respectively, who had commissioned this Ligurian, a man from Genoa, Christopher Columbus, to sail, well, Dominic,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。克里斯托弗·哥伦布——这位来自利古里亚的男子，此前勉强从我的君主那里得到了三艘船来进行这次航行，因为他们曾认为他所说的话完全是异想天开——他从西方对极之地归来了。那是彼得·马蒂尔（Peter Martyr），一位意大利人文主义者，曾担任斐迪南和伊莎贝拉宫廷的牧师，这二位分别是阿拉贡国王和卡斯蒂利亚女王。他们曾委托这位来自热那亚的利古里亚人克里斯托弗·哥伦布去航行，嗯，多米尼克，
to the Indies, to China, to Asia. And Columbus comes back from his first voyage across the Atlantic thinking that he's got to Asia, or at least he has to say that he thinks he's got to Asia because that's the entire basis of the contract and the commission, isn't it? That's right. And that's where we left it in the previous episode. Yes. So in our first two episodes, we talked about the background, didn't we, to Columbus's voyages. And then the second episode, we talked about voyage number one. And you're absolutely right, Tom. Does Columbus genuinely believe he's found Asia? I think he
去印度，去中国，去亚洲。哥伦布从他第一次横渡大西洋的航行中归来时，认为他已经到达了亚洲，或者至少他必须宣称他认为自己已经到了亚洲，因为这是合同和委任的全部基础，不是吗？没错。我们上一集就是在这里结束的。是的。所以在前两集里，我们讨论了哥伦布航行的背景，对吧？然后第二集里，我们讨论了第一次航行。你说的绝对没错，汤姆。哥伦布是真心相信他找到了亚洲吗？我想他
does, but there's obviously some slight element of convincing himself, isn't there? He needs to persuade Ferdinand and Isabella. He needs to persuade all these people who've invested, as we talked about last time, Genoese sort of bigigs in in the court of the the catholic monarchs as they're called they put up the money for this and everybody is expecting they have not done this for the thrill of discovery they have done this because they want spices and gold uh from cafe from chipangu as they call it and from india and columbus has come back with this formula of the indies which is nice and vague it sort of hints at islands that are probably off the coast of China. But the interesting thing I would say is that almost everybody, I mean, he was turned down
是的，但显然其中也有一些自我说服的成分，对吧？他需要说服斐迪南和伊莎贝拉。他需要说服所有这些投资的人——正如我们上次所说，在天主教君主（他们是这么称呼的）宫廷里热那亚的那些大人物们，他们为这事出了钱，而每个人都在期待着。他们做这件事可不是为了探索的刺激，他们这么做是因为他们想要香草和黄金，嗯，来自契丹（Cathay）、来自他们所称的吉庞古（Chipangu），以及来自印度。而哥伦布带回来的关于印度的说法，既美妙又模糊，它隐约暗示着那些可能位于中国海岸外的岛屿。但我要说有趣的是，几乎所有人都——我的意思是，他被
so many times by the Portuguese and Spanish because they said, it can't be done. We don't believe that you can just sail so quickly to Asia from Europe. We just don't believe it's possible. And they have been kind of proved right because he hasn't gone to Asia. And when he comes back, they think, well, we're still right. He clearly has not been to Asia. I'm reluctant. Well, I'm not reluctant. I'm keen to do some cod-psychologizing. Only someone as driven and self-confident as Columbus could possibly have done what he did. So do you think that to an extent, he can't possibly carry on being the great explorer unless he cleaves to this conviction that he was right and everyone
葡萄牙人和西班牙人拒绝了那么多次，因为他们说，这根本做不到。我们不相信你能从欧洲这么快就航行到亚洲。我们就是觉得这不可能。事实也证明他们某种程度上是对的，因为他并没有去亚洲。当他回来时，他们想，看吧，我们还是对的。他显然没有去亚洲。我很不情愿——好吧，我其实很乐意做点拙劣的心理分析。只有像哥伦布这样极具驱动力和自信的人，才可能做出他所做的事情。所以你认为，在某种程度上，他不可能继续作为一个伟大的探险家，除非他坚守这个信念：他是对的，而所有
else was wrong? It's the foundation stone of the entire sense he has of himself. We talked before, didn't we, about how he probably isn't university educated, how he's an autodidact who has this tremendous sense of himself as the man of destiny who is tilted against the kind of mainstream media, the establishment. And psychologically, I think it's impossible for him to back down. I don't think he's equipped to say, my goodness, I have come back and I've discovered something absolutely extraordinary. There is a whole new continent out there. I mean, you mentioned Peter Martyr, the great humanist. He is one of the first people to use the phrase, a new world. think is it nova
其他人都是错的？这是他对自己整体认知的基础。我们之前讨论过，对吧？他可能没有接受过大学教育，他是个自学者，内心里有一种强烈的使命感，觉得自己是那个敢于对抗主流媒体、对抗建制派的天选之人。从心理上讲，我认为他不可能退缩。我觉得他不具备这种心态去说：“天哪，我回来了，我发现了一件极其了不起的事情。外面有一整片全新的大陆。”我的意思是，你提到了彼得·马蒂尔这位伟大人文主义者。他是最早使用“新世界”一词的人之一，我想是
orbis or something like that yeah lots of people sense and that's an amazing thing and yet the great irony is that columbus as you said psychologically cannot bring himself to face the reality that there is another continent because he has staked everything on this sort of lunatic idea that you can sail across the Atlantic in a matter of a couple of weeks and basically get to the coast of China. And the whole way through, there's this weird double thing, not just on the part of Columbus, but on the part of the Spanish monarchs as well, that on the one hand, they're perfectly happy to kind of cull to the idea that they've discovered Asia. But at the same time, they're kind of
新世界（Nova Orbis）还是别的什么？是的，很多人都有这种感觉，这真是件了不起的事。然而最大的讽刺在于，正如你所说，从心理上讲，哥伦布无法强迫自己去面对存在另一块大陆的现实，因为他把一切都押在了那个疯狂的想法上——即你可以在短短几周内横渡大西洋，基本上就能到达中国海岸。整个过程中，存在着一种奇怪的双重性，不仅哥伦布如此，西班牙君主也是如此：一方面，他们非常乐意顺应他们已经发现了亚洲的这种说法；但与此同时，他们也
operating also on the assumption that these are new lands that they can grab Asia. But at the same time, they're kind of operating also on the assumption that these are new lands that they can grab. The fact that at the back of the minds of both Ferdinand and Isabella is the possibility that they have discovered, as they see it, virgin territory, because they start to set diplomatic wheels in motion, don't they? Particularly with the papacy. They do, exactly. So as early as the 3rd and 4th of May, 1493, so Columbus has been back basically a matter of weeks. They get the Pope Alexander Borgia to issue an encyclical, a top pope, top pope, very famous pope.
同时在某种程度上假定，这些是可以掠夺的新土地，他们可以夺取亚洲。但与此同时，他们也同时在某种程度上假定，这些是可以掠夺的新土地。斐迪南和伊莎贝拉内心深处的另一个事实是，他们可能已经发现了他们所认为的处女地，因为他们开始在外交上采取行动了，不是吗？特别是与教皇交涉。确实如此，完全正确。因此，早在1493年5月3日和4日，也就是哥伦布回来基本上才几周的时间，他们就让教皇亚历山大六世（Alexander Borgia）发布了一道通谕，这是一位顶级教皇，顶级教皇，非常著名的教皇。
So he's a Valencian, isn't he? So he is close to them. He issues a papal bull that basically says there is a line down the earth from the, I mean, I'm quoting, from the Arctic pole, which is in the north to the Antarctic pole, which is in the south, the line lying at a distance from what we vulgarly call the Azores and Cape Verde, 100 leagues away. He says basically everything to the west of that line is fair game for Spain and everything, The implication is that everything to the east of that line. So that's Africa and the eastern route to India.
所以他是瓦伦西亚人，对吧？所以他跟他们的关系很近。他发布了一份教皇诏书，基本内容是：在地球上画一条线，从——我的意思是，我是在引述——北方的北极点延伸到南方的南极点，这条线距离我们俗称的亚速尔群岛和佛得角一百里远。他基本上是说，这条线以西的一切都归西班牙，而一切……其潜台词是，这条线以东的一切。所以那是非洲和通往印度的东方航线。
That's for Portugal. But as you said, the implication is this is virgin territory. These are lands that can be claimed. People can be converted to Christians. In other words, it's not ruled by the emperor of China. Yeah. They don't want a war with China. I mean, I would thought even the Pope wouldn't feel that he can give away China.
那是属于葡萄牙的。但正如你所说，这里的潜台词是这里是处女地。这些是可以被宣称主权的土地。人们可以被转化为基督徒。换句话说，这里不是由中国皇帝统治的。是的。他们不想跟中国打仗。我的意思是，我想即使是教皇也不会觉得自己有权把中国送人。
No, exactly. To Spain. So there is a kind of strange double thing there. And so the fact that there is this ambivalence, this ambiguity, clearly in a kind of deep sense of uncertainty as to what exactly it is that Columbus has found means inevitably that there has to be a second voyage almost straight away. The Catholic monarchs, as they're called, Ferdinand and Isabella, they pay him a pension. They confirm his titles. So he's a don. Yes, exactly. That's what he's always wanted. I mean, that's why he's done this, because he wants status and respectability. But they also say, right, you should start taking colonists now. So what's interesting with this is they're clearly rushing because they are worried about the Portuguese. The Portuguese are the sort of premier league explorers and colonizers. The Spanish are a bit of a rung below. So they have to hurry. And Columbus, when he came back, he'd
不，确实如此，送给西班牙。所以这里面有一种奇怪的双重性。这种矛盾心理和模糊性，加上对于哥伦布到底发现了什么在深层意义上的不确定性，意味着几乎必然马上就要进行第二次航行。天主教君主（他们是这么被称呼的），也就是斐迪南和伊莎贝拉，发给他一份年金。他们确认了他的头衔。所以他成了“唐”（Don）。是的，没准。这就是他一直想要的。我的意思是，这就是他为什么要这么做，因为他渴望地位和受人尊敬。但他们同时也说：“好啦，你现在应该开始带殖民者过去了。”所以这里有趣的地方在于，他们明显在赶时间，因为他们担心葡萄牙人。葡萄牙人是顶级联赛级别的探险家和殖民者。西班牙人则要低一个档次。所以他们必须抓紧。而哥伦布回来的时候，他曾被
been taken to Lisbon, hadn't he? He had. So the Portuguese know about it. So there's a slight anxiety about that. In fact, for all they know, the Portuguese may be sending ships even now. And there are lots of rumors that are reaching the Spanish that Portuguese may be about to send expeditions of their own. They're not, of course, because the Portuguese are much more interested in the more lucrative route around Africa. But the Spanish king and queen agree that they will pay colonists basically to go to this new territory. So they organize about 1,500 people, almost all of them men. Queen Isabella doesn't want women to go. She says that women who go by definition would be prostitutes. So she doesn't like the idea of women going.
带去了里斯本，不是吗？是的，他去过。所以葡萄牙人是知道这事的。因此存在一丝焦虑。事实上，据他们所知，葡萄牙人现在可能就已经在派船了。而且有很多传言传到西班牙人耳朵里，说葡萄牙人可能正准备派遣他们自己的探险队。当然，他们并没有这么做，因为葡萄牙人对绕过非洲那条更有利可图的路线更感兴趣。但西班牙国王和王后同意他们将出资让殖民者基本上前往这片新领土。于是他们组织了大约1500人，几乎全部是男性。伊莎贝拉女王不希望女性去。她说去的女性按定义来说就是妓女。所以她不喜欢女性去的想法。
They are told that they're going to settle. They're going to look for gold. Columbus has come back talking about gold. So they're going to establish gold mines. Now this is different from what the Portuguese are doing right away. So when the Portuguese go around Africa and when they do their own expeditions, they're really going purely to trade. They establish ports, they buy slaves, they buy ivory, they buy gold, but they don't really want to set up little towns of their own, the Portuguese. That's why when you tell the story of Portuguese colonization in Africa and India, there's no sort of big lumps of Portuguese territory. They're all just ribbons and on the coast. The Spanish straight away are thinking, well, maybe we'll build towns and we'll do what we did on the Canary Islands. We could even have plantations and things. And what they did in Spain itself, in Iberia itself with the Reconquista. Yeah. So they've got experience of doing this because when they
他们被告知他们要去定居。他们要去寻找黄金。哥伦布回来时谈到了黄金。所以他们要建立金矿。这与葡萄牙人从一开始的做法不同。所以当葡萄牙人绕过非洲进行他们自己的探险时，他们纯粹是为了贸易。他们建立港口，买奴隶，买象牙，买黄金，但葡萄牙人并不真正想建立自己的小城镇。这就是为什么当你讲述葡萄牙人在非洲和印度的殖民历史时，并没有那种大块大块的葡萄牙领土。它们都只是沿海的一条条带状领地。而西班牙人一上来就在想，嗯，也许我们可以建城镇，我们可以做我们在加那利群岛做过的事。我们甚至可以搞种植园之类的事情。还有他们在西班牙本土、伊比利亚本土通过“收复失地运动”（Reconquista）所做的事情。是的。所以他们有这方面的经验，因为当他们
drove back the Moors, as they would have called them, they established towns. They also converted people. So Isabella in particular is really keen on the idea of conversion. There's that tension, which this episode really brings out between when we get there, the local people, are we going to make them our workforce, basically just force them to become our slaves effectively? Or should we actually be making Spaniards of them? She gives explicit instructions to Columbus that he is to treat the Indians, as they're calling them, very well and lovingly. That word lovingly, amorosamente, that was a word they had used when they had conquered Granada. So that was how they had said, we will treat the population of
击退摩尔人（他们当时是这么称呼的）时，他们建立了城镇。他们还让人改宗。因此，伊莎贝拉尤其热衷于改宗的想法。这里存在着一种紧张关系，这也是本集真正突显出来的：当我们到达那里时，当地人，我们是把他们当作劳动力，基本上强迫他们变成我们的奴隶吗？还是我们实际上应该把他们变成西班牙人？她给哥伦布下了明确的指示，要他非常友善、充满爱意地对待他们所称的印第安人。那个词“充满爱意”（amorosamente），正是他们在征服格拉纳达时用过的词。这就是他们当时所说的，我们将充满爱意地对待格拉纳达的人民。所以再次说明，这里存在着一种与收复失地运动的连续性，因为就在哥伦布归来并与他们进行这些对话的同一时刻，他们正忙于在西班牙国内强迫穆斯林和犹太人改宗基督教。所以这是征服格拉纳达的一年后，是驱逐拒绝改宗的犹太人的一年后。从某种意义上说，西班牙国王对待其穆斯林和犹太少数族裔的方法，也明显体现在哥伦布的探险中，因为他带了许多身经百战的卡斯蒂利亚勇士。但同时，他也第一次带了一位神父。所以他带了一位
Granada lovingly. So again, there's that sort of continuity between the Reconquista, because at this very moment that Columbus is coming back and having these conversations with them, they are busy converting the forced conversion of Muslims and Jews to Christianity within Spain. And so this is a year after the conquest of Granada, a year after the expulsion of Jews who refused to convert. And so in a sense, that is the approach that the Spanish kings are bringing to their Muslim and Jewish minorities is also evident in Columbus's expedition, because he is taking lots of very, very battle-hardened Castilian warriors. But he is also, for the first time, he's taking a priest. So he is taking a
名叫贝尔纳多·布伊尔（Bernardo Bruil）的加泰罗尼亚修士。是的，他最后恨上了哥伦布。是的，他们全都严重偏离了正轨。但你也有一个后来变得非常著名的人——胡安·庞斯·德莱昂（Juan Ponce de Leon），他日后将发现佛罗里达。后来离去，传闻说他试图寻找不老泉。没错。我想这据认为相当令人悲伤，或许并非完全属实。贝尔纳多·布伊尔这位修士，以及这个最后去寻找不老泉的家伙。所有西班牙人对新世界的涉足，都是随着哥伦布一同出发的。我的意思是，参加第二次航行的另一个人——迭戈·委拉斯克斯（Diego Velazquez），他就是那个派埃尔南·科尔特斯去墨西哥、随后又与科尔特斯彻底闹翻的总督。
Catalan friar called Bernardo Bruil. Yeah, who ends up hating Columbus. Yes, they all go badly off-piste. But you also have a man who'll become very famous, Juan Ponce de Leon, who in due course will discover Florida. Then go off and the story is that he's trying to find the fountain of youth. That's right. I think is apparently rather sadly, perhaps not entirely true. Bernardo Brayil, this friar, and this guy who's going to end up searching for the fountain of youth. All of Spanish engagement in the New World is there going off with Columbus. I mean, one of the other guys who goes on this second voyage, Diego Velazquez, he is the governor who sends Enan Cortes to Mexico and then falls out massively with Cortes.
而委拉斯克斯与科尔特斯的宿怨贯穿了整个阿兹特克帝国灭亡的故事。所以有大量的西班牙内部恩怨在发生，对吧？从一开始就有。我们有过这样一个类比，有些听众可能觉得荒谬，但我认为确实站得住脚。我们讨论过哥伦布试图筹集资金，他就像某种科技创业者。这有点像那些创建了脸书（Facebook）之类公司的人的故事。是的。他们很快就闹翻了，因为里面牵扯了大量的资金。有很强的职业自豪感。这些人，以西班牙人的情况来看，对自己的特权和地位非常嫉妒。
And the Velazquez-Cortes feud kind of runs right through the story of the fall of the Aztec empire. So there's a lot of Spanish feuding going on, isn't there? There is right from the beginning. We had that analogy that some listeners may have considered ridiculous, but I think actually does stand up. We talked about Columbus trying to raise money and being a sort of tech entrepreneur. And it's a bit like that story of the people who, you know, created Facebook or something. Yes. They all fall out really quickly because there's a lot of money involved. There's a lot of professional pride. These are people, in the Spanish case, who are very jealous of their own privileges and their own status.
但这也与宗教狂热交织在一起，不是吗？因为当他们在讨论：印第安人有灵魂吗？印第安人——他们是这么称呼的——他们有灵魂吗？他们能成为西班牙人吗？他们能成为基督徒吗？还是他们生来就是奴隶？这些可不是枯燥的学术辩论。他们是真心相信这些东西的。显然，这会对人们的生活、他们自己的财富产生现实世界的影响，
But they also, it is mixed up with religiosity, isn't it? Because when they are talking about, do the Indians have souls? The Indians, they call them. Do they have souls? Can they become Spanish? Can they become Christians? Or are they just servile? These are not dry academic debates. They really believe this stuff. And obviously it has real world consequences for people's lives, for their own wealth,
所有这类事情。而且哥伦布回来后还说印第安人爱好和平。这就是建立殖民地的计划得以制定的基础。当然，当他向他们分发玻璃珠并说“让我们做点鱼类交易或别的什么”时，他们是爱好和平的。但显然，当他说“我现在要奴役你们”时，他们就不那么爱好和平了。当然。或者逼迫他们在矿里挖金子。或者逼迫他们挖金子。正是在那个时候他说：“哦，天哪，这些人是食人族。”
all of these kinds of things. And also Columbus has come back and said that the Indians are peaceable. And that is the basis on which the plans are being made to found colonies. And of course they're peaceable when he's handing beads to them and saying, let's trade some fish or whatever. But obviously, they're less peaceable when he says, I'm now going to enslave you. Of course. Or make you dig gold from mines. Or make you dig gold. And that's the point at which he says, oh, my gosh, these people are cannibals.
是的。所以他非常迅速地从一个极端跳到了另一个极端。不管怎样，我们该讲讲他的航行故事了，不是吗？他们在9月25日出发。他们现在有17艘船了。上次是3艘，这次是17艘。显然是一次规模大得多的行动。而哥伦布依然在“尼娜号”上。
Yes. So he leaps very quickly from one extreme to the other. Anyway, we should tell the story of his voyage, shouldn't we? They set off on the 25th of September. They've got 17 ships now. So three last time, 17 this time. Obviously a much, much bigger operation. And Columbus is still on the Nina.
是的，他们依然有“尼娜号”。所以其他的都完蛋了，但他还有“尼娜号”。因为“圣玛丽亚号”在第一次航行期间在暗礁上搁浅损毁了，不是吗？是的，还被改造成了纳维达德堡（Fort of Navidad）。没错。那那座堡垒怎么了？这也是险境的一部分。是的，这确实是险境的一部分，因为他上次留下了那39个人，并说：
Yes, they've still got the Nina. So the others are dead ducks, but he's still got the Nina. Because the Santa Maria was wrecked, wasn't it, on a reef during Voyage 1. Yes, and made into the Fort of Navidad. Exactly. So what's happened to that? That's part of the jeopardy. Yes, it is part of the jeopardy because he's left those 39 guys last time saying,
“别担心，我们很快就会回来。”他们会怎么样呢？他们回去了。这次航行稍微直截了当一些，因为显然他们以前走过这条路。他们首先在多米尼克（Dominica）靠岸。他们身处加勒比群岛中。在多米尼克，从后世的角度来看，发生了一个不妙的时刻。所以他们一上来就开始绑架原住民作为奴隶。他们要把他们送回西班牙。他们接下来去了瓜德罗普（Guadalupe），在那里他们说发现了食人族存在的证据。
don't worry, we'll be back soon. What's going to happen to them? Back they go. The voyage is a little bit more straightforward this time because obviously they've done it before. They pitch up first at Dominica. They're in the Caribbean islands. On Dominica, there is a bad moment, I think, from the point of view of posterity. So straight away, they start kidnapping indigenous people as slaves. They're going to send them back to Spain. They go next to Guadalupe, and there they say they've come across evidence of cannibalism.
所以所有这些——我们上次稍微谈到了加勒比人（Caribs），对吧？他们带了一位名叫阿尔瓦雷斯·昌卡（Alvarez Chanca）的医生，他说他们发现了塞满骨头的房屋。有各种关于阉割男孩并把他们喂胖的传闻，诸如此类的事情。毫无疑问，我认为西班牙人是相信这一点的。我的意思是，我们不可能知道这究竟有几分真实。但我认为西班牙人毫无疑问地相信他们找到了证据。
So there are all these sort of, we talked a little bit about the Caribs last time, didn't we? They have a doctor with them called Alvarez Chanca, and he says they've found houses full of bones. There's all this stuff about castrating boys and fattening them, all of this sort of stuff. And there's no doubt, I think, that the Spanish believe this. I mean, it's impossible for us to know how true or not it is. But I think the Spanish undoubtedly believe that they have found evidence.
好吧，他们说在他们的锅里有混有人肉的鹅肉，而人体其他部位则被固定在烤肉叉上准备烧烤。在另一座房子里，西班牙人发现了头骨，食人族小心翼翼地把它们保存下来当作箭头，因为他们没有铁。西班牙人发现了一个年轻人最近被砍下的头颅，上面还沾着血。我的意思是，现代学者对此有何看法？他们是凭空捏造的吗？我不认为他们一定是在凭空捏造。我的意思是，完全有可能其中存在某种程度的食人现象。我们知道，在更加复杂的“美索美洲”社会中——阿兹特克人是最明显的例子——存在活人献祭，
Well, they say that in their pots were geese mixed with human flesh while other parts of human bodies were fixed on spits ready for roasting. In another house, the Spaniards found bones which the cannibals carefully preserved for points of their arrows for they have no iron. The Spaniards discovered the recently decapitated head of a young man still wet with blood. I mean, what's the thinking of scholars today on that? Are they just making that up? I don't think they necessarily are making it up. I mean, it's perfectly possible that there was an element of cannibalism. We know that in much more sophisticated Niso-American societies, so the Aztecs are the most obvious. There's human sacrifice
并且存在非常有限的某种仪式化的食人现象。所以这并非不可能真的是食人，但我们只是很难确定。因为有人认为这是某种欧洲中心主义。是的，完全如此。但你可以争辩说，
and there's very limited sort of ritualistic cannibalism almost. So it's not impossible that it's cannibalism, but we just, it's very hard to be sure. Because the argument is that this is kind of Eurocentric. Yes, exactly. But you could argue that
谴责西班牙人认为他们是食人族这件事本身就是欧洲中心主义，因为你没有接受食人可能完全没问题这种观点。我想是的。我想如果你持一种非常非常前卫的立场，你可能会说：你在谴责食人族群体。是的，叫什么名字来着？那个沉迷于当食人族、结果被全网封杀的家伙。那个演员。艾米·汉默（Armie Hammer）。
to condemn the Spaniards for thinking that cannibalism is you know that they're cannibals is itself eurocentric because you're not buying into the idea that cannibalism might be absolutely fine i suppose so yes i suppose if you were taking a very very very avant-garde position you might say uh you're condemning the cannibal community yeah what's his name the guy who who was intoning the cannibal community. Yeah. What's his name? The guy who was into being a cannibal, who got cancelled? The actor. Armie Hammer.
艾米·汉默。那个演员。他对这事会有什么看法？我的意思是，他最近又复出了，汤姆。我觉得现在有一种轻微的看法，认为他可能被冤枉了。因为他其实不是个食人族，对吧？不，他不是。这些可能只是短信里的幻想。
Armie Hammer. The actor. Would he have views on this? I mean, he's recently resurfaced, Tom. I think there's a slight sense now that he may have been hard done by. Because he wasn't actually a cannibal, was he? No, he wasn't. These may have been text fantasies.
我们严重偏离主题了。严重偏离主题了，是的。好吧，听着，我们偏离得太远了——所以这是未经证实的，我认为是未经证实的。我认为这完全取决于历史学家自身的政治视角，真的。所以如果你是一位常驻马德里、与西班牙保守党关系密切的历史学家，你就会说，这个地方实际上到处都是食人族，到处都是人头。哦，对，到处都是人头，太无耻了。而如果你身处一所特别进步的美国大学，你就会说这完全是无耻之尤，你是一种中心主义的投射。有一件事真的很有趣，那就是在瓜德罗普——我觉得这太迷人了——我在不同的账目中读到了关于这事的记录。在瓜德罗普，发生了一起臭名昭著的事件：
We've gone massively off-piste. Massively off-piste, yeah. So well listen we've gone massively so so it's unproven i think it's unproven i think it absolutely depends on the political perspective of the historian actually yeah so if you're a historian based in madrid who's very close to the conservative party in spain you say this place was actually teeming with cannibals heads everywhere oh yeah heads everywhere disgraceful and i think if you're at a particularly progressive american university you say this is everywhere disgraceful and i think if you're at a particularly progressive american university you say this is absolutely disgraceful you're a central projection one thing that is really interesting is that on guadalupe now i found this fascinating so i was reading about this in different accounts on guadalupe there's a notorious incident where
哥伦布他们正在抓捕奴隶，哥伦布带走了一个女孩，并把她交给了米格尔·库内奥（Miguel Cuneo）这个人。而库内奥写了一份关于这件事的记述，他把她交给了米格尔·库内奥。库内奥写了一份关于这件事的记述，他说：“起初情况很糟糕。我不得不殴打她，她才向我的示好妥协。但最后，我们达成了共识，她似乎是在妓院里学过她的技巧。”而历史学家休·托马斯勋爵（Lord Thomas）在其关于西班牙帝国建立的宏大三部曲中的著作《黄金之河》（Rivers of Gold）里，写下了这样一句非同寻常的话：“这是新世界中关于云雨之欢的第一手记载。”我的意思是，他在2003年读到这句话时，距今才20年。但现在没有人会写出这样的句子了。所有人都会说：这是强奸。
columbus they're taking slaves and columbus takes a girl and he gives her to a guy called miguel cuneo and cuneo writes an account of this and he gives her to a guy called Miguel Cuneo. And Cuneo writes an account of this and he says, it was pretty poor at first. I had to beat her to get her to yield to my advances. But in the end, we came to an agreement and she appeared to have learned her arts in the school of whores. And in his book, Rivers of Gold, which is part of his mighty trilogy about the foundation of the Spanish Empire, the historian Hugh Thomas, Lord Thomas, has the extraordinary phrase, this was the first account of lovemaking in the new world. I mean, he read that in 2003, only 20 years ago. But now nobody would write that sentence. Everybody would say, this is rape.
这是性暴力。我认为，每当你读到对哥伦布的任何控诉，尤其是在美国，这起事件总是占据非常大的比重，人们会说这是这一切的开端。而事实的真相是，这确实是接下来一切的开端，因为西班牙人（你知道的）存在大量的性暴力。一部分原因在于伊莎贝拉曾说过——我不是在为之辩护，但我是说伊莎贝拉曾说过：去抓。所以你基本上有一群穿着衣服的家伙带着剑，在岛上四处游荡，而当地出生的土著女性却赤身裸体，他们只是抓起她们就带走。所以，西班牙人态度中的那种紧张关系再次显现得淋漓尽致：那种认为他们有权随心所欲地使用本地女性的感觉。是的，我想这你知道的，是一个古老古老的故事：参与战争的男性，强奸一直是这种活动的一种持续背景。
This is sexual violence. violence and i think that whenever you read any indictment of columbus particularly in the united states this incident always looms very large and people say this is the beginning and the truth of the matter is it is the beginning of what's going to follow because the spanish you know there is a lot of sexual violence well and part of it is because isabella has said i mean i'm not excusing it but i'm saying isabella has said take. Right. So you basically have all these blokes roaming across the islands with swords and unclothed native born women who they're just sort of seizing and making off with. So again, there is a tension there in the Spanish attitudes is absolutely evident. The feeling that they have the right to use the native women as they want yeah which i guess is you know an ancient ancient story men who who are engaged in war rape is a constant kind of background yeah to that activity at the same time the reason they haven't taken women to serve their sexual needs is because of Isabella's very Christian
与此同时，他们之所以没有带女性来满足性需求，是因为伊莎贝拉有着非常强烈的基督徒性道德观念。这也是被输出到新世界的东西。那种认为贞洁是一种美德的观念。我对泰诺人（Tainos）的性道德了解还不够，不知道他们是否有这种概念，但我对此表示怀疑。我们无从得知。我们对他们的了解实在太少之又少了，因为从长远来看——剧透警告——他们最终都以这样或那样的方式死光了。所以除了西班牙人自己写的记录之外，我们对他们知之甚少。而对于这些记录，我们同样不知道其中有多少是主观投射。换句话说，我们出于最终源自基督教性道德概念的原因去谴责对这名女子的强奸。
sense of sexual morality. And that also is something that is exported to the new world. The sense that chastity is a positive. I don't know enough about Tainos sexual morality to know whether they would have had that concept, but I would doubt it. We don't know. We know so little about them because they're basically, in the long run, I mean, a big spoiler, they all die one way or another. So we know so little about them other than from the accounts that the Spanish themselves wrote, which again, we don't know how much projection there is. So in other words, we condemn the rape of this woman for reasons that ultimately descend
没错。是的。你是说这种谴责本身就是一种欧洲中心主义的表现？15世纪末西班牙人态度中存在的这种紧张感，在现代西方，我们依然是这种遗产的继承人。这种紧张感依然存在于我们的论述之中。这倒是不假。但我不认为当地人，也就是泰诺人，会觉得这没什么大不了的，因为我们知道他们并不这么认为，他们进行了如此惨烈的抵抗。所以我认为他们对西班牙人的行为感到非常震惊。不过确实有这样的描述：在关于食人族的记载中，也有人掠夺女性并将她们当作奴隶使用。是的，这倒是真的。如果这不仅仅是欧洲人的主观投射，我一点也不会感到惊讶。
from Christian notions of sexual morality. Right. Yeah. You're saying it's kind of the condemnation itself is a form of Eurocentrism. That tension that exists in Spanish attitudes back in the late 15th century, in the modern West, we remain the heirs of that. That tension remains within our discourse. That's true. But I don't think the local people, the Tainos, I don't think they think this is fine because we know that they don't because they resist it so bitterly. So I think they are really shocked by the Spanish behaviour. But there is descriptions of, you know, among the cannibalism, those accounts of people carrying off women and using them as slaves. Yes, it's true. It would not surprise me if that is something more than just, again, European projection.
女性可以被劫持并实质上遭到强奸、被当作奴隶使用的想法，似乎确实是那些岛屿上原住民文化的一部分。如果你往最黑暗的方向去想，你会说这是所有人类历史的一部分，不是吗？是的，但其中存在一种非常精确的天主教对性道德的理解，那是会谴责这种行为的。关于哥伦布及其声誉，有趣的一点是，关于他的争论几乎立刻就开始了，不是吗？没错。所以这些并不是什么新鲜事。
The idea that women can be abducted and essentially raped, used as slaves, would seem to have been part of the culture of the native peoples on those islands. Well, if you're being very bleak, you would say part of all human history, wouldn't you? Yeah, but there is a very precise Catholic understanding of sexual morality that would condemn that. One of the interesting things about Columbus and his reputation is that the arguments pretty much start straight away, don't they? Exactly. So these are not new.
这并不是21世纪对性别的“觉醒”（woke）态度的产物。这些是当时就已经在进行、并且根植于西班牙文化和西班牙道德的辩论，从一开始就是如此。正如你所说，我们对泰诺人的了解还不够，无法得知他们的态度。但从西班牙人对他们行为的记述来看，他们当时在互相征伐，互相奴役和劫持彼此的人民。是的，我认为这是真的。他们的行为非常恶劣，但他们一直在为自己的恶劣行为争论不休，争论这些行为是否像其中一些人所谴责的那样糟糕。这绝对是晚期中世纪西班牙基督教思想世界的产物。
This isn't the kind of product of 21st century woke attitudes to gender. These are debates that are being had and that are bred of Spanish culture, Spanish morality, right from the beginning. As you say, we don't know enough about Tainos to know what their attitudes were. But it would seem from what the Spanish write about what they're doing, that they are fighting one another and that they are enslaving and abducting each other's people. Yeah, I think that's true. They're behaving very badly, but they're arguing all the time about their own bad behavior and whether it is as bad as some of them are condemning it. And that is absolutely a product of the intellectual world of sort of late medieval Spanish Christendom.
换句话说，后来由新教列强细化的“黑色传说”（Black Legend），其实源于西班牙人自己的报告。好吧，它的伟大倡导者——也就是你在你的书《统治》（Dominion）中写过的那位——巴托洛梅·德拉斯·卡萨斯（Bartolome de Las Casas），那位谴责虐待印第安人的伟大神父。他写了大量关于哥伦布的文章。是的。他在某些方面是“黑色传说”的鼻祖，这个传说认为西班牙人自取其辱。不管怎样，他们在安的列斯群岛（Antilles）瞎转悠。
So in other words, the black legend, as it comes to be refined by the Protestant powers, derives from what the Spanish themselves are reporting. Well, the great exponent of it, who you've written about in your book Dominion, I think, Bartolomeo Lescazas, the great priest who condemns the mistreatment of the Indians. And who writes a lot about Columbus. Yes. He is the progenitor in some ways of the black legend, the idea that the Spanish have disgraced themselves. Anyway, so they've been faffing around on the Antilles.
他们发现了许多岛屿。蒙特塞拉特（Montserrat），是以加泰罗尼亚的一座修道院命名的。安提瓜（Antigua），是以塞维利亚大教堂里圣母玛利亚的圣玛丽亚德安提瓜（Santa Maria de Antigua）命名的。维尔京群岛（Virgin Islands），是以圣乌苏拉（St. Ursula）命名的，诸如此类。他们终于回到了伊斯帕尼奥拉岛（Hispaniola）。纳维达德（La Navidad）的情况怎么样了？哥伦布留下建立的那个城镇，已经被彻底摧毁，所有人都死光了。我的意思是，基本上就是这个结果。似乎发生的情况是，那39名男子被当地人屠杀了——就是哥伦布曾说过“他们非常爱好和平，人很好，会成为优秀臣民”的那些人。他们被屠杀的原因，几乎可以肯定的是，就像所有的西班牙探险队一样，他们内部发生了内讧，而且他们通过在乡间四处寻找黄金和掠夺女性来败坏自己的名声。
They discover lots of islands. Montserrat, it's named after the monastery in Catalonia. Antigua, that's named after the Santa Maria de Antigua, the Virgin in the Cathedral in Seville. The Virgin Islands, they're named after St. Ursula, so on and so forth. They finally get back to Hispaniola. And how is La Navidad doing? The town that Columbus had left, it's been completely destroyed and everybody's dead. I mean, that's basically the result. And what seems to have happened is that the 39 men have been massacred by the locals, the people who Columbus had said, oh, they're very peaceable and they're lovely. They'll make
是的，又一次。所以又是黄金和强奸。是的。这是本集以及整个西班牙对新世界殖民的一个巨大主题。哥伦布决定他其实没法因为这事去惩罚当地人。
fine subjects. And the reason they've been massacred is almost certainly, well, like all Spanish expeditions, they've fallen out among themselves, but also they have been disgracing themselves by going out around the countryside looking for gold and stealing women. Yeah. Actually, once again. So gold and rape again. Yes. That's a huge theme of this episode and indeed of the Spanish colonization of the New World generally. Columbus decides he's not really in a position to punish the locals for this.
于是他跟当地酋长握手言和，说“过去的事就让它过去吧”。然后他去建立了一个新城镇，他将其命名为伊莎贝拉（La Isabella）。你知道的，哥伦布是一位非常优秀的航海家和领航员。好吧，我的意思是，他不是个很好的制图师，但他是个优秀的领航员诸如此类的。但他是个极糟糕的城市规划师和行政管理者。他建立的所有城镇总是选错地方。一位历史学家说：“伊莎贝拉港口条件恶劣，选址极其愚蠢。”我想，“选址极其愚蠢”这句话简直可以作为哥伦布的墓志铭。
So he sort of shakes hands with the local chief and says, you know, we'll let bygones be bygones. Then he goes off to found a new town, which he calls La Isabella. You know, Columbus is a very good mariner and a good navigator. Well, I mean, he's not a very good cartographer, but he's a good navigator and all this stuff. He's a terrible town planner and administrator. All his towns are always in the wrong place. One historian says, Isabella had a bad harbor and the site had been chosen foolishly. And I think the site had been chosen foolishly as might as well be Columbus's epitaph.
费利佩·费尔南德斯-阿尔梅斯托（Felipe Fernandez Armesto），曾写过一本极佳的哥伦布传记，将其描述为“新世界中第一个也是命运最悲惨的城镇”。他还提出了一个绝妙的观点：那里夜间有幽灵般的哭号，还有无头男子的阴森游行。哇。这可不是什么好兆头，对吧？不，不。这太不吉你了。你建立了一个城镇，结果里面有无头男子的阴森游行。
Felipe Fernandez Armesto, who wrote a great biography of Columbus, describes it as the first and worst fated township in the new world. And has this brilliant thing that there were ghostly wailings by night and of shadowy processions of headless men. Wow. That's not a good sign, is it? No, no. That's very ominous. You found a town and you have shadowy processions of headless men.
这对于房地产价格可没什么帮助。汤姆，在房产网站上它的评分绝对不高。没有。就在这个时候，你真的能看出哥伦布的情绪，我想说。他带着如此巨大的希望而来。满怀希望或许是个错误的表达，因为那暗示了一种轻快的理想主义，而我认为这绝对不是哥伦布的风格。他是个相当阴郁的家伙，你不觉得吗？
Property prices are not going to be helped by that. It's not highly rated on Zoopla, Tom. No. It's about this point that you can really see Columbus's mood, I would say. He's come with such sort of high hopes. High hopes is maybe the wrong expression because that implies a sort of jaunty idealism, which I don't think is ever Columbus's. He's quite a gloomy bloke, isn't he, don't you think?
是的。他总是期待着被人从背后捅刀子或者背叛，因为他总是遭遇背叛。好吧，而且他和修士闹翻了，不是吗？因为那位本该表现得“打左脸把右脸也送过去”的修士，却主张狠狠打击当地人，惩罚他们消灭了纳维达德的定居者。他属于修士谱系中好战、崇尚武力的那一端的战士僧侣，对吧？
Yeah. He's always expecting to be stabbed in the back or betrayed, because he always is being. Well, and he's had a big bust-up, hasn't he, with the friar? Because the friar, who you'd think would be very turn-the-other-cheek, is all for having a crack at the natives and punishing them for wiping out the settlers of Navidad. He's a sort of warrior, from the warrior-mon monk end of the friar spectrum, isn't he?
是的。所以哥伦布，凭良心讲，并没有买账，但他们吵翻了。他们还因为木材的事吵翻了。说也奇怪，这位修士完全是前后矛盾的，因为正是在他们建造伊莎贝拉的时候，黄金连影子都找不到。大家都觉得有点悲惨。
Yes. And so Columbus, to do him credit, is not buying into that, but they have a bust up. They also have a bust up about the tree. Weirdly, the friar is completely inconsistent because it's about this point when they built that Isabella, the gold is nowhere to be found. They're all a bit sort of miserable.
而哥伦布显然需要证明他的投资能有回报。他可不是为了养生或者搞慈善才被派出来的。我的意思是，宗教改宗是其中的一部分。但斐迪南和伊莎贝拉指望他送回黄金或有价值的东西。而他开始觉得，这东西也可以是活生生的人。所以，再次拿你的初创企业类比，他收到了大量的投资。大家都在玩着跳跳球，坐在开放式办公区里，开开心心地把钱烧光，
And Columbus is clearly saying, well, he needs to show a return on his investment. He has not been sent for the good of his health or as charitable. I mean, the conversion is a part of it. But Ferdinand and Isabella are expecting him to send gold or something valuable back. And he starts to think that could be human beings. And so to compare, again, your startup analogy, he's received lots of investment. They're all with their space hoppers and their open plan things where they're all having a lovely time burning up money,
但他们完全没有显示出任何利润。没错。他需要证明这在财务上是有利可图的。没错。他简直就像试图将推特（Twitter）变现的埃隆·马斯克（Elon Musk），不是吗？他正准备开始向人们的蓝V认证收费之类的。是的。所以很显然，他在考虑奴隶制。
but they're not showing any profits at all. Exactly. And he needs to show that this is financially remunerative. Exactly. He's Elon Musk trying to monetize Twitter, isn't he? He's about to start charging people for their blue ticks or whatever. Yes. So clearly he is thinking about slavery.
为什么要搞奴隶制？好吧，他会说：为什么不呢？他来自这样一个世界——我们在上一集里聊过——西班牙已经有十万名奴隶了，柏柏尔人、东欧人、黑人非洲人，形形色色、应有尽有的人。而且他们一直在加那利群岛使用奴隶。所以从他的角度来看，奴隶制可能显得完全自然。但为什么不呢？天主教传统里有这样一种观点：
And why slavery? Well, he would say, why not? He's come from a world, we talked in the previous episode, there are 100,000 slaves already in Spain, Berbers, Eastern Europeans, Black Africans, people of every sort of possible description. And they were using slaves on the Canary Islands. So from his point of view, slavery probably just seems completely natural. But why not? There is a Catholic tradition of
每个人都拥有上帝赋予的权利，这种思想源自12世纪的法律思想。这在西班牙各大学、特别是修士中间非常有代表性。因此，奴隶制是一种道德邪恶的观念在西班牙是存在的，这也是哥伦布不得不与之搏斗的东西。所以再次说明，关于奴隶制的辩论，在哥伦布时期的西班牙，认为有理由谴责奴隶制这种制度并不是一种历史错位。好吧，汤姆，但这样说对吗——这方面你比我更懂——当时普遍的想法是，如果你对待的人是那种无可救药、根深蒂固且无法被拯救的异教徒，奴隶制就没问题？这存在争议。这是有争议的。这是有争议的。
the idea that every human being has God-given rights, descended from 12th century legal thought. And this is very, very representative in Spanish universities and particularly among the friars. So that notion that slavery is a moral evil is present in Spain and something that Columbus will have to wrestle with. So again, the debate over slavery, it's not anachronistic to say that there are reasons for condemning slavery as an institution in Columbus's Spain. Well, is it not right to say though, Tom, you'll know more about this than me, that the general thinking at the time is that slavery is fine if the people you're dealing with are kind of dyed in the wool, inveterate infidels who cannot be saved. It's debated. It's debated. It's debated.
然后理由会更充分；而如果是那些有希望成为基督徒的人，伊莎贝拉女王就是这么想的。她当时在西班牙。这一集和下一集的重大主题之一就是，她不断收到关于哥伦布等人奴隶化他人的报告，或者他用船只运回了奴隶，而她说：“你们在干什么？这些是我的臣民。”她梦想着一个将所有人带入基督怀抱的世界，并为此感到惊恐。
And then it's more reason, whereas if it's people who had the possibility of becoming Christians, this is certainly what Queen Isabella thinks. She's back in Spain. And one of the big themes of this episode and the next episode is she keeps getting reports of Columbus and Co. enslaving people, or he is sending back ships with slaves on. And she says, what are you doing? These are my subjects. She dreams of a world in which they are all brought into the bosom of Christ and is horrified.
我的意思是，放眼未来，我们提到过的拉斯卡萨斯，他对奴隶化印第安人的想法感到震惊，其原因正是你所说的：这些人是拥有权利、可以被引向基督的人。是的。因此他建议奴隶化非洲人。是的，太离谱了。这绝对是抹黑他的一笔。但在日后，他开始意识到这也是邪恶的。他开始摸索着这样一种观点，即奴隶制作为一种制度本身就是邪恶的。因此，这种
I mean, to look ahead, Las Casas, who we've mentioned, he's appalled at the idea of enslaving Indians for precisely the reason you say, that these are people with rights who can be brought to Christ. Yeah. And therefore he suggests enslaving Africans. Yes, extraordinary. That's very much a kind of a black mark against him. But in due course, he comes to recognize that that is evil as well. And he's kind of groping his way towards the idea that slavery as an institution itself is evil. So the potential
认为“奴隶制可以被接受”的整个观念被谴责的潜力是存在的。仅仅说西班牙人很残酷，句号，这是不够的。他们也有这种观念，这也是他们输出到新世界的思想包袱、紧张关系和复杂性的一部分。是的，完全正确。我想我们之前讨论过，或者在我们的俱乐部会员加更节目中讨论过，墨西哥裔英国历史学家费尔南多·塞万提斯（Fernando Cervantes）的书《征服者》（Conquistadores）。他非常非常认真地看待西班牙人的宗教狂热。他写了许多关于西班牙修士及其神学思想的文章。他明确指出：如果你对金钱津津乐道，而忽略了他们每天思考和谈论的一个极其重要的部分，那就是他们对待这种把人们引向上帝的使命是极其认真的。
is there for this whole idea that slavery is acceptable to be condemned. It's not enough just to say the Spanish were brutal, full stop. They also have this notion, and that also is part of the package of ideas and tensions and complexities that they are exporting to the new world. Yeah, that's absolutely right. I think we talked about it before, or we talked about it in one of our bonus episodes for our club members, the book Conquistadores by Fernando Cervantes, who's a Mexican historian based in Britain. And he takes the Spanish religiosity really, really seriously. He's written lots about Spanish friars and things and about their theological thinking. And he says exactly that. interested in money, you're missing a really important part of what they thought about and what they talked about every day, which is they took this stuff about bringing people to God
在这里对——关于奴役是可以被接受的这个观点进行纳迉式的谴责。仅仅说西班牙人残宝，到此为止，这还不够。他们同时也持有这种看法，而这也是他们正在向新世界输出的观念、张力和复杂性组合的一部分。是的，那绝对是对的。我想我们之前讨论过这个问题，或者我们在为俱乐部会员准备的一个片芲节目中讨论过，即驰麻斯·壞利伏斯所著的《征服者》一书，他是一位在英国的墨西哥历史学家。他非常非常省阳地区分开待西班牙的宗教俤仰。他写过大量关于西班牙修士等内容以及他仇们的神学思考。他说的就是这个。如果你认为他们只是对钱有兴趣，那你就错过了他们每天思考和讨论的一个非常重要的部分，那就是他们开始将人们带刑上帝面前
and about what God wants. They took it incredibly seriously. And these debates were not just fig leaves for their own entrepreneurial ambitions. I mean, this was a huge part of the mentality. Well, it was the mentality they took to the new world. And I think that that is evident because we are the heirs of that tradition. The reason that we condemn slavery in part is because we are the inheritors of these ideas of why slavery is wrong. All right, Tom, we're in danger of turning the story of Columbus into an advert for your book.
以及上帝的意愿。他们对此极其严肃。而且这些辩论不仅仅是他们个人创业野心的遮羞布。我的意思是，这是他们心态中非常重要的一部分。嗯，这就是他们带去新世界的精神面貌。我认为这显而易见，因为我们是那种传统的继承人。我们之所以谴责奴隶制，部分原因正是因为我们继承了这些关于奴隶制为什么是错误的理念。好了，汤姆，我们快要把哥伦布的故事变成你书的广告了。
Heaven for Fed. So let's get to things aren't going well. And he decides to basically go off to cuba doesn't he so he sent expeditions into the interior looking for gold looking for slaves all of this stuff they were arguing they've fallen out a little bit with the locals because they're slaving and in april 1494 so they've been gone almost a year cumbers says things are not going well running out of food the natives aren't trading with us and stuff i'll tell you what i'm going to do i'll go to cuba the rest of you stay here and see how things work out which is i think is a very good sign of of why columbus is heartily despised by a lot of the people
上帝保佑美联储。所以让我们切入正题：事情进展不顺。于是他决定基本上离开去古巴，不是吗？所以他派探险队深入内陆寻找黄金、寻找奴隶、做所有这些事情。他们一直在争论，他们和当地人有点闹翻了，因为他们在抓奴隶。于是在1494年4月——他们已经离开将近一年了——哥伦布说，事情进展不顺利，食物快吃完了，当地人也不跟我们做生意等等。我告诉你们我要怎么做，我去古巴，你们其余的人留在这里看看情况如何。我认为这很好地说明了为什么哥伦布遭到很多人的痛恨。
that he's taken he's just such a poor leader and a poor manager of men i think so off he goes to cuba twitter's not working i'm going to go to mars yes pretty much so off he goes to Cuba. Twitter's not working. I'm going to go to Mars. Yes, pretty much. So off he goes to Cuba and I think we should take a break and we'll find out what happens next after the break. All right. See you then. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes,
他带走的人……他实在是个糟糕的领导者和糟糕的人事管理者，我是这么觉得的。所以他去了古巴。推特不好用，我要去火星。对，差不多就是这样。所以他去了古巴，推特不好用，我要去火星。对，差不多就是这样。所以他去了古巴，我想我们应该休息一下，中场休息后我们会知道接下来发生了什么。好的，回头见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐而已》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家播客，
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History. We are sailing off with Columbus to Cuba, where Dominic, rather magnificently, he claims to have seen the footprints of griffins. Yes. Well, don't forget, he also thinks Cuba is China. Well, right, because China's full of griffins. Full of griffins. Absolutely. Yeah, backed with them.
以及提前购买现场演出门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到《历史而已》。我们要和哥伦布一起起航前往古巴，在那里，多米尼克非常神奇地声称自己看到了狮鹫的脚印。是的。嗯，别忘了，他还以为古巴是中国。对，没错，因为中国到处都是狮鹫。到处都是狮鹫。绝对的。是的，到处都是。
Columbus has left these guys on Hispaniola, where everything's going wrong. They've sent back some ships to Spain. The Spanish monarchs have been busy doing a deal with the Portuguese called the Treaty of Tordesillas, which is going to definitively divide up the world between them. But they say, fine, we'll send some help back to the Caribbean to bail out these guys on Hispaniola. And as you say, meanwhile, Columbus has gone to Cuba because he thinks Cuba is part of the Asian mainland and he wants to investigate it. He finds the footprints of something that he thinks is a griffin. I mean, you know, we talked about that, didn't we,
哥伦布把这些人留在了伊斯帕尼奥拉岛，那里的一切都在出问题。他们派了几艘船回西班牙。西班牙君主们正忙着与葡萄牙人达成一项名为《托尔德西利亚斯条约》的协议，该协议将彻底瓜分他们之间的世界。但他们说，好吧，我们会派一些救援回到加勒比海，去解救伊斯帕尼奥拉岛上的这些人。正如你所说，与此同时，哥伦布去了古巴，因为他认为古巴是亚洲大陆的一部分，他想去调查一番。他发现了一些他认为是狮鹫脚印的东西。我的意思是，你知道的，我们讨论过这个，不是吗，
in episode one of this series about the world of the chivalric romances, Amazons, people with no ears, all these wacky ideas that people had about what was out there. And also the idea that there might be Prestor John, a great Christian king, waiting to come to the assistance of the Christians of Europe. And one of his crewmen sees a man dressed all in white. And so Columbus leaps to the obvious conclusion that it must be Prestor John. So he's clearly absolutely entered a world of chivalric romance, as you say, and wonders. Columbus, throughout all of this story, is a man under tremendous strain and pressure,
在本系列的第有关骑士传奇世界的节目中，亚马逊人、没有耳朵的人，人们对外面世界的所有这些古怪想法。还有这样一种想法：可能存在着约翰长老，一位伟大的基督教国王，正等待着前来援助欧洲的基督徒。他的一个船员看到一个全身穿白衣的人。于是哥伦布顺理成章地得出结论，这一定就是约翰长老。所以，正如你所说，他显然彻底进入了一个充满惊奇的骑士传奇世界。哥伦布在这个故事的始终，都是一个承受着巨大压力的人，
strain from his financial backers, from the king and queen of Spain. But also, he's a Genoese surrounded by Spaniards who all hate him. Also, sailing across the Atlantic is not a barrel of laughs. And he doesn't really know where he is. And everything is defying all his expectations. Yeah. The great Khan of China is nowhere to be seen. Yeah. These people are clearly not Chinese or Japanese.
来自他的金主、来自西班牙国王和王后的压力。而且，他是一个被所有讨厌他的西班牙人包围的热那亚人。另外，横渡大西洋可不是一件轻松的事。而且他其实并不清楚自己在哪里。一切都违背了他的所有预期。是的。中国的伟大可汗踪迹全无。是的。这些人显然既不是中国人，也不是日本人。
I think there's an argument that he hasn't lost his wits completely, but he's definitely getting a bit scrambled. Slight breakdown. Yeah. He makes all his men sign a statement that they have seen the beginning of kind of the Asian continent. And that if they'd gone further, they would have got to mainland China and met the Chinese emperor and stuff. And they sign this sort of contract that if they ever rescind that or contradict it, they will be fined 10,000 maravedis and they'll have their tongues, he'll cut their tongues
我认为有一种观点认为他并没有完全失去理智，但他的大脑确实有点混乱了。精神有点崩溃。是的。他让所有手下签署了一份声明，声称他们已经看到了亚洲大陆的开端。并且如果他们再走远一点，就能到达中国大陆并见到中国皇帝之类的。他们签署了这样一种契约：如果他们日后反悔或反驳此事，将被罚款1万马拉维迪，并且他们会被割掉舌头。
out. Yeah,ust sanctions. And the weird thing is that all the locals are saying, this is definitely not the mainland of Asia. We know that we live on an island and Columbus just will not have it. He says, well, they don't know what they're talking about. Mainstream media conspiracy kind of stuff. They're part of the mainstream media. They've been brainwashed by the press moguls. He then goes back to Hispaniola again after faffing around on Cuba. He's got dysentery, I think, by now. So he's ill for five months.
切掉。是的，真是严厉的制裁。而奇怪的是，所有当地人都说，这里绝对不是亚洲大陆。我们知道我们住在一个岛上，而哥伦布就是听不进去。他说，嗯，他们根本不知道自己在说些什么。这有点像主流媒体阴谋论那一套。他们是主流媒体的一部分。他们被媒体大亨洗脑了。他在古巴瞎折腾了一番之后，又回到了伊斯帕尼奥拉岛。我想他到这会儿已经得了痢疾。所以他病了五个月。
In the history books, there were sort of offhand remarks like, you know, Columbus is bedridden for five months or something. That's a pretty long time. He gets there. Every time Columbus leaves a small group of people on an island, he returns to find that most of them are dead. And in this case, about half of them are dead of syphilis because they've been molesting the locals again. And they've caught syphilis from the local population because syphilis is reasonably widespread in the Caribbean, but unknown in Europe. And this is more bad news that adds to Columbus's kind of discombobulation. And it's all very kind of heart of darkness, isn't it? Oh, yeah. It's apocalypse now.
在历史书中，有一些轻描淡写的评价，比如，你知道的，哥伦布卧病在床五个月左右。那可是相当长的一段时间。他到达那里时。每次哥伦布在某个岛上留下小批人马，他回来时都会发现他们大部分都死了。而在这次事件中，大约有一半人死于梅毒，因为他们又在骚扰当地人了。他们从当地人口中染上了梅毒，因为梅毒在加勒比海地区相当普遍，但在欧洲却不为人知。这又是一个坏消息，加重了哥伦布那种精神错乱的状态。这一切简直有点像《黑暗之心》，不是吗？哦，是的。简直是《现代启示录》。
It's white men going mad in tropical jungles. Yeah, that's a good comparison. All that kind of stuff. Because the more, the worse that things go, the worse they behave, I think it's fair to say, don't you? Yes. And I wonder also if for Columbus, there's the shadow of a kind of theological anxiety, because the fact that the Indians, as he calls them, when he sees them are naked and that this is an Edenic
那是白人在热带丛林中发疯。是的，这个比喻很贴切。诸如此类的事情。因为事情越糟糕，他们的行为就越恶劣，我想这样说很公平，对吧？是的。我也在想，对哥伦布来说，这其中是否笼罩着某种神学焦虑的阴影，因为印第安人——正如他所称呼的那样——当他看到他们时是一丝不挂的，而这是一个伊甸园般的
paradise, he lives in a fallen world and paradise no longer exists. I wonder if he's shadowed by a kind of dread that perhaps he is the serpent. He has brought evil into paradise. I don't know. But the sense that things aren't going well, his whole take that the Indians are peaceable, that they are Edenic, that they kind of embody a prelapsarian state. And now everyone is catching syphilis and raping and there are cannibals everywhere. And he's had the shits for five months.
天堂，而他却生活在一个堕落的世界里，天堂已经不复存在了。我在想，他是否被一种恐惧所笼罩：也许他自己就是那条蛇。他把邪恶带入了天堂。我不知道。但这种事情进展不顺的感觉，他原先认为印第安人是爱好和平的、他们是伊甸园般纯洁的、他们某种程度上体现了一种堕落前的状态。而现在每个人都在染上梅毒、强奸，到处都是食人者。而且他已经拉肚子拉了五个月了。
He's living out the whole doctrine of original sin. And compounded by the fact that he knows that in Spain, the pressure is building, that he has to show results. Right, because some of his enemies, including the friar, has gone back, haven't they? Well, they go back and they say to the king and queen of Spain, Columbus is an absolute waste of space. He's a terrible manager.
他正在把原罪的全部教条活生生地演绎出来。再加上他知道在西班牙，压力越来越大，他必须拿出成果来。没错，因为他的一些敌人，包括那个修士，已经回去了，不是吗？嗯，他们回去了，对西班牙国王和王后说：哥伦布简直是个废物。他是个糟糕的管理者。
He's chosen the worst town sites imaginable. But also he is behaving very badly with your Indians. You see, the Ferdinand and Isabella, the thought that these people are their subjects, they take this very seriously. They are very sort of jealous of their own power and status. They absolutely do not want Columbus to carve out an independent realm of his own on the other side of the ocean it's theirs and these are their people and for him to be killing them raping them enslaving them isabella in particular is is furious about this and columbus doesn't get this at all he keeps making this mistake so the beginning of 1495 he's been away now for more
他选的城镇地址简直糟透了。而且他对你们的印第安人行为非常恶劣。你看，对于斐迪南和伊莎贝拉来说，他们认为这些人是他们的臣民，他们对此非常认真。他们对自己的权力和地位有着很强的占有欲。他们绝对不希望哥伦布在大洋彼岸开辟一个独立的王国，那是他们的领地，这些人是他们的人民。而他却在杀害他们、强奸他们、奴役他们。尤其是伊莎贝拉，对此勃然大怒。而哥伦布对此完全摸不着头脑，他一直在犯这个错误。所以在1495年初，他已经离开
than 18 months or 18 months or so. He still hasn't got any decent amount of gold. He and his brother and a guy called Alonso de Ojeda, they go out across the island of Hispaniola and they're kidnapping Indians in larger and larger numbers. Sorry, I say Indians. They're obviously not Indians. They're Tainos. They're kidnapping these people in ever larger numbers and saying, well, they're all cannibals, godless cannibals, so it's fine. So, for example, in February, by that point, he seized about 1,600 locals, and he sends 550 of them home to Castile thinking, this is great.
超过18个月左右了。他依然没有弄到像样的黄金。他和他的兄弟以及一个叫阿隆索·德·奥赫达的家伙，在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛到处游荡，大量绑架印第安人。抱歉，我说的是印第安人。他们显然不是印第安人。他们是泰诺人。他们大量绑架这些人，并声称，嗯，他们都是食人者，是不敬神的食人者，所以没关系。因此，例如在2月，到那个时候，他已经抓捕了大约1600名当地人，并将其中550人送回卡斯蒂利亚，心想：这太棒了。
This is my monetization of my project, and I will be rewarded for this. About 200 of them die on the voyage. I mean, these are awful, awful stories. You know, they've been suffering massive culture shock, disease. They die of cold. They don't have clothes. It's just awful. By the time the rest of them get to Cadiz, about half of them are ill,
这是我的项目的商业化成果，我将因此受到奖励。其中大约200人在航行途中死亡。我的意思是，这些都是极其可怕、极其悲惨的故事。你知道的，他们一直在遭受巨大的文化冲击和疾病折磨。他们被冻死。他们没有衣服。简直太惨了。当其余的人到达加的斯时，大约有一半人已经生病了，
probably terminally ill. Isabella is outraged that he's doing this. I mean, she doesn't greet these people with delight at all. The horror of it reverberates down the generations because Las Casas, writing a generation later, says that Columbus destroyed two-thirds of the population in this kind of razzia. Yeah, that's right. Hispaniola. Well, this is again a thing where it depends on the political persuasions of the historian, because the issue about whether that's true is really hotly debated. My sense is that most historians think that's a massive exaggeration. They say there weren't enough Spaniards to cause that much damage, and that obviously the Tainos do end up dying out. But I think probably most historians would say this is actually because of later disease, smallpox and so on, maybe in the 1500s and 1510s after Columbus is dead. However, there's no doubt that Columbus causes a lot of damage.
很可能是绝症。伊莎贝拉对他的这种做法感到愤怒。我的意思是，她一点也没有高兴地迎接这些人。这种恐怖在后世一代代回响，因为拉斯卡萨斯在后来的著作中说，哥伦布在这场大清剿中摧毁了三分之二的人口。是的，没，伊斯帕尼奥拉岛。嗯，这又是一个取决于历史学家的政治倾向的问题，因为关于这是不是真的，其实一直争论不休。我的感觉是，大多数历史学家认为这是一个巨大的夸张。他们说当时没有足够的西班牙人来造成那么大的破坏，而且泰诺人最终确实消亡了。但我认为大多数历史学家可能会说，这实际上是因为后来的疾病，比如天花等等，可能发生在1500年代和1510年代哥伦布死后。然而，毫无疑问，哥伦布确实造成了巨大的破坏。
But again, I mean, it's as with the rapes. The idea that Columbus is pursuing a near-genocidal policy isn't kind of woke manufacturing in the 21st century. It is deriving from what Spanish writers are saying, who are almost contemporary with Columbus. Although one thing I will say is that Columbus is clearly, none of the Spanish are genocidal in the sort of strict meaning of the term. They absolutely do not want to kill the locals because they want them to live as labor rather like the caribs who capture people and keep them you know fatten them up then to eat they're not going to eat them but they're going to work them no but but but they they keep them
但话说回来，就像强奸事件一样。认为哥伦布在奉行近乎种族灭绝政策的观点，并不是21世纪“觉醒派”虚构出来的。它源于那些与哥伦布几乎同时代的西班牙作家所说的话。不过我要说的一点是，哥伦布显然——没有哪个西班牙人在该词的严格意义上是进行种族灭绝。他们绝对不想杀死当地人，因为他们想让他们作为劳动力活下来，有点像加勒比人，他们抓捕人类并把他们养起来，你知道的，把他们喂肥了然后吃掉——他们不是要吃他们，而是要让他们干活。不，但是……但是他们把他们留下来
you know and they keep the women don't they this is the this is the story that they keep the women and breed them to raise children like livestock the caribs do or the spanish the caribs do so again you know this is there's a sense i mean one, one wonders, is this a kind of, I don't know, I don't want to go all Freudian, but operating in the subconscious of the Spaniards that they're projecting anxieties about what they are doing onto the Caribs. Oh, that's interesting. I hadn't thought of it that way. Maybe.
你知道的，他们留下了女人，不是吗？这就是那个说法，他们留下女人并像牲畜一样繁殖她们来抚养孩子，加勒比人是这么干的，还是西班牙人？加勒比人是这么干的。所以你看，这其中有一种感觉——我的意思是，人们不禁会想，这是否是一种，我不知道，我不想表现得太弗洛伊德，但这是否在西班牙人的潜意识中运作，他们把自己对自身行为的焦虑投射到了加勒比人身上？哦，这很有意思。我之前没这么想过。也许吧。
I mean, what's definitely true is that Columbus now really just thinks of the locals. All that stuff about, oh, they're lovely people, very nice, friendly. That's all gone. That is all gone. He thinks about them now purely as labor units. So he develops a new system of tribute. And this is the ancestor of the encomienda system that the Spanish later instituted in the Caribbean, which is basically all adult Tainos must provide tribute to the Spanish crown largely by work.
我的意思是，可以肯定的是，哥伦布现在确实只把当地人看作劳动力单位。所有关于“哦，他们是可爱的人，非常友善、友好”的那套说辞全都烟消云散了。那些全都没了。他现在纯粹把他们看作劳动力。于是他开发了一种新的纳税系统。这就是后来西班牙人在加勒比海地区建立的“监护征赋制”的鼻祖，基本上就是所有成年泰诺人都必须向西班牙王室缴纳赋税，主要通过劳务的形式。
So basically they'll either hand over gold or they'll hand over cotton or they'll work for you. And when they've paid off, they will be given a disc to wear around their necks as a sign they've paid off their tribute. And if they don't have this disc, they can be worked to death basically. I mean, this is a wholly alien way of understanding how labor should be organized. I mean, who, God knows what they think about this. We don't have any sources at all, really, to tell us what they think. But one could assume that they don't like it. Yeah, definitely. Their whole world has been turned upside down. The Spaniards are also,
所以基本上，要么上缴黄金，要么上缴棉花，要么为你干活。当他们交清赋税后，会发给他们一个戴在脖子上的圆盘，作为他们已经交税的标志。如果没有这个圆盘，他们基本上就会被劳役至死。我的意思是，这是一种完全异质的方式，去理解劳动力应该如何组织。我的意思是，天知道他们对这种事作何感想。我们其实没有任何史料来告诉我们他们的想法。但我们可以假设他们不会喜欢。是的，绝对的。他们的整个世界都被颠倒了。西班牙人当然也
of course, bringing over animals. So the Columbian Exchange. The Columbian Exchange. Yeah. So they're taking back chili peppers and squashes and things. Pineapples. But they brought over animals like horses, sheep. Rats.
带来了动物。也就是哥伦布大交换。哥伦布大交换。是的。所以他们带回了辣椒、南瓜之类的东西。菠萝。但他们带来了马匹、绵羊等动物。老鼠。
They're trampling across the agricultural ecosystem the Tainos have built. They're making it impossible for them to continue the sort of horticultural or the hunting, fishing lifestyle that they had previously practiced. So that's actually destroying their world. The Spanish don't do that. Again, they don't do that from genocidal intent. They were always going to bring their own animals over.
它们践踏着泰诺人建立的农业生态系统。这使得泰诺人无法继续他们先前实行的那种园艺或狩猎、捕鱼的生活方式。所以这实际上是在摧毁他们的世界。西班牙人并非故意这么做。再说一次，他们不是出于种族灭绝的意图。他们本来就打算把自己的动物带过来。
I mean, there's no alternative universe in which they don't. But the unanticipated consequence of that is it completely destroys the world on which the locals rely. So all this is going on. What is happening in Spain? In Spain, the Catholic monarchs are getting really hot onto the collar about all this. They realise basically they have to sort it all out by about 1495.
我的意思是，不可能存在一个他们不把动物带过来的平行宇宙。但这样做的未预后果是，它彻底摧毁了当地人赖以生存的世界。所有这些事情都在发生。西班牙那边发生了什么？在西班牙，天主教君主们对此感到非常焦躁不安。他们意识到基本上必须在1495年左右把这一切理顺。
People keep coming back from the Caribbean and saying it's an absolute shambles. Columbus is mad. He's treating everybody very badly. We need to do something about it. First of all, they break his monopoly. So they had given him a monopoly. And then in April 1495, they issue a new decree that basically says anybody now can go. As long as they promise to follow the rules, you can fit out your own private ventures. To use our sort of venture capital to tech pioneer analogy that's opening up the
人们不断从加勒比海回来，说那里简直是一团糟。哥伦布疯了。他对所有人都很粗暴。我们得做点什么了。首先，他们打破了他的垄断地位。此前他们曾授予他垄断权。然后在1495年4月，他们颁布了一项新法令，基本上宣布任何人现在都可以去了。只要他们答应遵守规则，你就可以组建你自己的私人风险企业。用我们那种风险投资到科技先驱的比喻，这就向所有人开放了
technology to everybody you know you can if you can raise a ship you can raise a crew if you will do as you're told you can set up your own search engine yes exactly exactly they send an official called juan aguado off to um hispaniola at the end of 1495. And he is told, you know, find out what's going on. Tell Columbus we're very concerned or this. I mean, do they think that he's gone the full Marlon Brando by this point? Some of the people around them, definitely. They're confessors and chaplains and bishops and things. Maybe people who've always distrusted Columbus are saying to them,
技术，你知道的，如果你能筹集到一条船，如果你能招募到船员，如果你听从指挥，你就可以建立你自己的搜索引擎。是的，完全正确，完全正确。他们在1495年底派了一名叫胡安·阿瓜多的官员去伊斯帕尼奥拉岛。并指示他，你知道的，去查明发生了什么。告诉哥伦布我们非常关心此事。我的意思是，他们觉得他此时已经完全变成马龙·白兰度了吗？他们身边的某些人绝对这么觉得。他们的告解神父、随军牧师、主教之类的人。也许那些一直不信任哥伦布的人对他们说，
I mean, it's also such an important thing. I think he's Genoese. So, you. So he's a hired gun from a foreign country, and he's got no one really at court to plead for him. He's got no network of relatives at court, patrons and all that who are pleading his case. But he's very good at pleading his own case, isn't he? He is. So he's always able to turn it back when he gets back himself. Kind of end up kind of bending them to his will but that's what he decides he has to do so he ends up thinking i've got to go back he does he says he says to himself i have to go back and then he does something very very strange which i think is part of that slightly nervous breakdown element and
我的意思是，这也是一件如此重要的事情。我认为他是热那亚人。所以，你看。所以他是一个来自外国的外援，在宫廷里没有人真正为他辩护。他在宫廷里没有亲戚网络、没有赞助人以及所有那些为他申辩的人。但他很擅长为自己辩护，不是吗？他是的。所以他每次自己回去时，总能扭转局势。某种程度上最终还是能让大家屈服于他的意志，但这就是他决定必须要做的，所以他最后觉得我必须回去，他确实这么做了，他对自己说：我必须回去。然后他做了一件非常非常奇怪的事情，我认为这属于那种轻微精神崩溃的表现的一部分，
even historians themselves you know who know far more about this than we do, clearly find it baffling. He decides to go back, but he does so, he's grown a beard and he's dressing as a Franciscan friar. You see, I don't think that's weird at all. Well, I mean, I can't remember which historian it is. Maybe Cervantes says a bizarre decision. I don't think it's bizarre. I think he's making a statement about himself as, we talked about the symbolic weight of his names,
甚至连历史学家自己——他们对这段历史的了解远超我们——显然也对此感到匪夷所思。他决定回去，但他回去时，留了胡子，穿着方济各会修士的长袍。你看，我一点也不觉得这奇怪。嗯，我的意思是，我不记得是哪个历史学家了。也许塞万提斯说这是一个离奇的决定。我不觉得离奇。我认为他是在为自己发表一种声明，就像我们谈到他的名字的象征意义一样，
that he's the Christ bearer and he's the dove, the embodiment of the spirit. And that the idea that the world is entering the age of the spirit is particularly associated with the Franciscans. Yes. So in that sense, maybe he's casting himself as the vehicle of the Holy Spirit. Well, I think it's definitely PR. I think he's definitely going back, slightly Uriah Heapish, bringing his hands and saying i'm incredibly humble i'm the servant of the lord yeah so he pitches up in there in his robes in his in his franciscan outfits they kind of raise their eyebrows but as you say he's very persuasive
他是基督的承载者，他是白鸽，是圣灵的化身。而世界正在进入圣灵时代的这种观念，与方济各会有着特别的联系。是的。所以从这个意义上说，也许他把自己塑造成了圣灵的载体。嗯，我认为这绝对是公关。我认为他绝对是在走回去，有点像尤利娅·希普那种卑躬屈膝的样子，搓着手说：我极其谦卑，我是主的仆人。所以他穿着长袍、穿着方济各会的服装出现在那里。他们有点挑起眉毛，但正如你所说，他极具说服力。
i mean it's like kind of very predatory capitalist companies who kind of woke wash he's christian washing him it's fly washing i mean you could always tell the most predatory companies because they're always the ones that are most pious, have the most pious advertising. Ben and Jerry's. Yeah, exactly. So that kind of thing. He's the Ben and Jerry's of 15th century exploration.
我的意思是，这就像那些极具掠夺性的资本主义公司进行“觉醒洗白”一样，他这是在进行基督教洗白，这是“飞洗白”（Fly-washing）。我的意思是，你总是能认出最具掠夺性的公司，因为它们往往是那些最虚伪、广告做得最虔诚的公司。本杰瑞冰淇淋。对，绝对的。就是那种调调。他就是15世纪探险界的本杰瑞。
Right. There's a whole massive metaphor here with fish food. That's my favourite Ben and Jerry's ice cream, but we won't go in for that. He gets back. He works his magic to some extent. So he actually gets permission from them, sort of tentative theoretical permission to go back again,
这里面关于鱼类食品有一个巨大的隐喻。那是我的最爱本杰瑞冰淇淋，但我们就不深入探讨那个了。他回去了。他在某种程度上施展了他的魔力。所以他实际上得到了他们的许可，某种试探性的理论许可，可以再次返回，
a third voyage, taking more settlers. And they say to him, you have to convert the locals. That's really important. Stop doing all this. But by this point, he's actually slightly struggling to recruit people because word has spread in the ports of Spain. He's a bit mad. He's very annoying. Everything goes wrong. So actually, for a time, he's becalmed. And in that time, he's writing increasingly weird things about how it's definitely Asia, how evil words have been spread about him.
进行第三次航行，带上更多的定居者。他们对他说：你必须让当地人皈依。这非常重要。别再搞那些事情了。但到了这个时候，他在招募人员方面其实有点举步维艰，因为西班牙港口的消息已经传开了：他有点疯。他非常烦人。事情总是出错。所以实际上，有一段时间他滞留不前了。而在那段时间里，他写下了越来越诡异的东西，内容关于这里绝对是亚洲、关于别人是如何散布关于他的恶毒谣言。
He's starting to make these strange comparisons. He's digging out things from the Bible and saying there have been prophecies about a place called Tarshish. Do you know what Tarshish is? Yeah, Tarshish is a place in Spain that is associated with gold and silver. Well, he's sort of digging up all stuff about this and he's saying this is foretold. He's very interested in solomon so he sometimes says that the caribbean these are probably places that traded with solomon yeah and then other times he says i'm actually king david and ferdinand is solomon that's the analogy i'm i'm laying the foundations i mean when you're comparing yourself with david i mean jesus obviously did that and got away with it. Well, he didn't, did he? No, he didn't, actually. He didn't get away with it.
他开始做这些奇怪的对比。他从圣经里翻出一些东西，说曾经有过关于一个叫他施的地方的预言。你知道他施是什么地方吗？是的，他施是西班牙的一个地方，与金银有关。嗯，他差不多把所有关于这方面的资料都翻出来，并说这一切都是预言好的。他对所罗门非常感兴趣，所以有时他说加勒比海这些地方可能就是跟所罗门做过生意的那些地方。是的，然后其他时候他又说：我其实是达芬奇……不，大卫王，而斐迪南是所罗门。这就是我的类比，我在打下基础。我的意思是，当你把自己和大卫相比时——耶稣显然这么干过而且蒙混过关了。嗯，他没有，对吧？不，他其实没有。他没有蒙混过关。
Jesus tried that and didn't get away with it. And Columbus, well... He wasn't crucified. No, he wasn't crucified. So actually, it's a plus for Columbus. So we should leave Columbus there. He's in Spain. He wants to do another voyage. He's slightly bonkers. Everything has gone wrong. And we should do a fourth episode shouldn't we tom where we talk about his third and fourth voyages which is some ways less consequential but a matter stranger things happen full of brilliant details yes including an extraordinary metaphor for the shape of the globe that columbus comes up with after he's been a long time at sea
耶稣尝试过那一套但没有蒙混过关。而哥伦布嘛……他没有被钉上十字架。不，他没有被十字架处死。所以对哥伦布来说这其实是个加分项。所以我们应该把哥伦布留在那里。他在西班牙。他想进行另一次航行。他有点疯疯癫癫的。一切都出了岔子。我们应该录制第四集，对吧，汤姆？我们可以在那一集里谈谈他的第三次和第四次航行，这些航行在某些方面影响较小，但却更加离奇，充满了精彩的细节。是的，包括关于地球形状的一个非凡的比喻——这是哥伦布在海上待了很长时间后想出来的。
yeah a slightly not safe for work metaphor i think it's fair to say plus there's some heroic canoeing which is always good in a podcast and we shall be debating when we where columbus stands in history and what we make of him yes a hero or villain well would we ever be so simplistic tom who knows find out now long-term listeners to the rest is history will know exactly what i'm going to say now. If you are a member of the rest is history club, the crew, as I like to think of them, you can listen to that right now. And if you're not, well, you can subscribe right now. Just go to Apple podcasts, the rest is history feed, do the free trial or visit restishistorypod.com.
是的，一个不太适合在工作时听的比喻，我觉得这样说很公允，此外还有一些英雄式的独木舟漂流，这在播客里总是喜闻乐见的内容。我们还将讨论哥伦布在历史上的地位以及我们对他的看法。是的，是个英雄还是恶棍？好吧，我们怎么会如此简单化呢，汤姆？谁知道呢。现在就去寻找答案吧。熟悉《历史而已》的长期听众一定知道我接下来要说什么。如果你是《历史而已》俱乐部的成员——也就是我喜欢称呼的“船员”——你现在就可以收听那一集。如果你还不是，嗯，你现在就可以订阅。只需前往苹果播客、《历史而已》订阅源，注册免费试用，或者访问 restishistorypod.com。
Sign up for our voyage. We're not mad. Is that the right analogy to comparing ourselves with Columbus? Yeah. We're not mad. No, please join us. Right. And on that bombshell, we'll see you next time for episode four.
报名加入我们的航程吧。我们可没疯。把我们自己和哥伦布作比较，这个比喻对吗？是的。我们可没疯。不，请加入我们。好啦。伴随着这个重磅炸弹，我们下期第四集再见。
Goodbye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史而已》。想要收听独家播客、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐而已》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家播客和提前购买现场演出门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。